e
e e
it being 10:30 I'm going to officially
call to order the public works and
highways presentation of the capital
budget
orientation welcome Mr Shay
good morning chisay from the legislative
budget Assistance office um everybody
should have before them a tan sleeve and
in that sleeve you should have three
documents should have the what we have
referred to as the
catalog you should have a bond offering
statement and then you'll have our
presentation on top of that you should
have the governor's recommended capital
budget your name should be on that in
bottom corner so that don't get confused
and share it with somebody else by
accident
um and I'll touch up on all these
documents as I go along and and I'm
going to be brief because the treasure
is um supposed to be here at 11 o'clock
so and you don't want to listen to me
for too too long so the purpose of the
document that's got LBA and big letters
on it and the capital budget orientation
is it's basically meant to be a One-Stop
shop for you if you're interested in
knowing different aspects um and we just
to start when you flip the page um on
the back side of the cover is contact
information so my name's there my
telephone number and my email and it
there's also a link and that's to our
web page the LBA web page where all the
capital project documents will be
located um as agencies come and present
to you and we hand you a piece of paper
from the agency that paper will be um
stored on our web page so that you can
access that um when you're not wanting
to look at the paper or you don't have
the paper in front of
you the next page is the table of
contents it gives you just a very um
brief overview of what's contained in
the document you got the capital budget
statutes um the overview of the capital
budget process we throw in a docket for
the capital um budget for House Bill
25 um there's a compare report which our
office prepares um and then the house
bill 25 is adopted and then um a couple
of pieces of uh some some minor changes
that occurred this last operating uh
capital budget
um that I'll just draw your attention
to so I'm not going to go through the
statutes I mean again that's the reason
I show you that this is how or drives
what happens with the capital budget so
that that tells when um the process
should start what types of things should
be included um it's not just
administrative Services there are things
like CTE from the Department of
Education and there's a statute that
guides how they submit that for the
capital budget and how much of that they
put in there
but if I could move you to um
page nine of the document it's going to
be the overview of the capital budget
process so this process starts almost a
year ago the agency start thinking about
what they would like to do for Capital
Improvements or capital projects within
their agency and then they submit um by
May 1st uh their list to the governor's
office or to administrative services for
them then um to be developed into a
compiled list of all the agencies that
the governor will have for um their
presentations um in June so there's the
capital budget presentations in June of
a
year from there so the and there's a
summary in this document that you know
there's was close to $700 Million worth
of capital projects actually more than
that because almost 600 was the um
prison um of projects that the agency's
asked for it's a major wish list it's
everything they could potentially need
money for once the governor has their
hearings they work with the public works
committee and some of their people to
determine which projects the agency's
presented should be further reviewed um
and
submitted in the catalog so this this
trims down the numbers that were
presented in June and from here the
governor May pick some of these projects
to present in the pink document to you
doesn't necessarily mean that a project
that is in the pink document was in the
catalog that it's not binding in any way
but the um items in the catalog have a
lot more detail behind them than what
you actually see in the catalog so that
U Department of administrative services
division of Public Works Works through
these projects works with the agencies
and comes up with cost estimates and
that's where they get some of the
numbers and sometimes the numbers that
you might see that come from the catalog
and then an agency brings in something
that they had done earlier than that
might be different and that's part of
the reason is that there's some costs
that um administrative Services Public
Works will'll try to update and and try
to get you to the most um current
information to have before
you then February 15th the governor by
February 15th the governor needs to hand
her budget over to the legislature and
then it comes in this case to the house
so the pink document is the governor
aot's
recommendation if you pick up the pink
document for just a moment and you flip
the first
page so these are the agencies that um
have a project recommended by her and
what you have there is the total
funds and then the general fund portion
in this case there's a the governor is
recommending $143 million in general
fund Capital Appropriations for members
of this committee who have been on this
Committee in the past um you've often
talked about a number between 120 and
125 um so just so you know it's it's up
a little bit from what you typically see
uh I suspect the treasurer will speak to
you about this as
well so the this committee will go
through the
process um recommend a capital budget to
the Full House the house will accept
that potentially and if they do it would
go to the Senate and the process would
start all over again Senate would pass a
capital budget potentially it would come
back to the house to consider if they
made any
changes a committee of conference may be
asked for at that point and at their
Committee of conference uh selected
members of uh this committee and of the
Senate capital budget committee would
meet in a committee of conference to
iron out any differences and from there
it would be passed to the governor to
sign off and and put into law
potentially so that's the process um
hopefully by the end of June this is all
done
maybe if you flip to page 11 it's going
to it's going to look like this this is
the compare sheet that I put together
for this committee so I'll take all the
projects that the governor has
recommended in her budget I'll put it on
the list there'll be a column that's um
blank that has the house decisions each
one of you will get as we start to meet
with agencies I'll provide this to you
so next week when agencies start coming
in to present to you their Capital um
project ideas and what they would like
you to fund for them you'll be able to
keep tab on you know what decisions this
committee might make I will update the
document um at the end of each meeting
if any decisions are made
and at the next meeting provide the
updated version but as well it will be
on our website
if you turn to page
177 that is the house bill 25 that was
signed into law in
2023 so if you were interested in what
was done the last capital budget you
have that document here if you look on
page 18 you're going to see a
highlight on row 22 and
23 it's related to the winnisquam
regional CTE
Center so what happened there is that in
House Bill 2 there was language put in
to say fund this project through the
education trust fund don't bond it
because the capital budget had already
moved
forward um they put um language in House
Bill 2 that was contingency that
basically said if this house bill 25
gets adopted don't fund it with capital
appropriation use the education trust
fund pay cash and that can be seen
on page
41 and 42 you'll see again some shaded
areas that's where the CTE were funded
this last operating uh this last budget
cycle um again for members who are
returning most years the CTE are funded
through the capital
budget the 2023 House Bill 25 was the
first time it wasn't funded through
there it was funded directly with the
educ ation trust fund
Appropriations this time if you look in
the governor's recommended the CTE is
back in there so it looks to be uh being
asked as a capital appropriation this
time and rightly so since the education
trust fund um probably couldn't support
um additional
CTE if you turn to page 43
and then going on for the next couple
Pages these would be all the um requests
that were made back in June at the
governor's capital budget hearing so
each agency and how much they were
asking for uh was 1.1 billion in general
funds so I was I cut that short and the
Department of Corrections was the
largest number they had 707 million but
just over 600 million was related to uh
a new prison
so the detail follows that for a couple
of pages um and then the last two pages
is basically uh just the rsas related to
the uh Capital project overview
committee and the long range Capital
planning utilization committee and I
only put them there because um some of
you may be appointed to that committee
and it just tells you how you got on
there you know it's very specific that
several Public Works members get
appointed to the capital project
overview and through the long range
Capital so that is just taking you
through that document ra rather quickly
um if there's any questions I'll take a
pause here but then I'll move on from
there I just have I just have one and uh
pardon me I don't have it in front of me
here I know we have a CT school I think
it's I guess my question is do we have a
backup CTE School in case they can't
come up with their part of the funding
we've had it in the past so they've only
they only have the one listed in the
capital um budget recommendation I don't
know if there's so let me back up the
Department of Education keeps a list of
the CTE and when they're due to be
considered for a capital appropriation I
don't know what the status of the list
is in terms of you know the entity after
the one that's in this budget where they
approached and where they can you know
asked if they would be able to pass it
locally if they had to that would be a
question I'd have to follow up with doe
on do we know if Jeffrey ringe has got
we don't know I don't know yet if
there's been approval in locally for
that or if it's just a placeholder with
anticipation for approval but I I can
ask the agency I think they're due to
see you next week right I can ask them
to be ready to respond to that when they
come before commissioner Ed bluk going
to be here or did he uh I don't believe
he's going to come into that meeting uh
I believe it's going to be uh Melissa
white who's the director of one of the
areas and then uh Mr beard who runs the
CTE program I know that that one two
banum we had uh we had that ball through
twice yep yeah okay um aside from that I
don't have any questions
uh anyway yes representative Brown thank
you Mr chairman just for clarification
again I'm new to this so I want to make
sure I understood what you were speaking
about on the page 40 in regard to the uh
Department of Education CTE renovation
projects you said that those projects
were previously approved under this
committee's budget before am I correct
but the governor has now taken these
projects and put in her capital budget
under the education trust f I just need
a clarification no so in in developing
the 2023 capital budget for 25 and 20
excuse me 24 and 25 um fiscal years the
CTE was in the um proposed oper capital
budget during the process of the
building the operating budget a decision
was made to take them out of the um
capital
budget and put it into the operating
budget there was two CTE projects last
time one was in the capital and one
ended up in the um House Bill 2
the decision was to just fund both
projects through House Bill 2 so
essentially they took cash out of the
education trust fund to pay for the CTE
projects instead of bonding
them what this Governor has proposed is
to go back to what has been the norm in
is to bond a capital appropriation for a
CTE thank you for that clarification
thank you Mr chairman representative
Jack uh thank you Mr chairman uh coming
back to the uh page 43 where there's a
billion something dollars in requests
isn't
that am I remembering we want the
agencies to ask for everything they
might possibly want and then prune from
there because sometimes you will see the
Press saying these Big Spenders want to
spend a billion dollars on what but
that's what we ask them to do so that's
what the capital budget process does it
says agencies give us everything so that
the governor can consider that that's
what this page 40 uh3 is it's all
everything that the agencies thought
that they might need at that time
obviously
68 months later new ideas might come up
or new issues may come up and so you you
may have to Pivot to address different
Capital issues but it gives you a sense
of what agencies might be asking
for they may not um get them this cycle
but maybe a heads up as to what you
might see for the next cycle as
well Chris so then our big thick book
should have the 1.1 billion just have
less than that it'll have less but but
it'll be close takes the 1.1 billion of
projects and the governor and their team
looked at and said okay here's projects
we would consider for a capital budget
okay so it's going to be less than that
um and then it comes down after that
then it comes down into our little pink
book which is what we'll be working off
of what this what this actually does and
it doesn't happen that frequently but
when we're in our and I'm going to call
it the pink book for clarification a for
right now will come up and the
Department of Corrections will only have
one item for something but when we go to
our binder you'll find out that
Department of Corrections will have four
or five different
requests and
frequently occasionally they'll come in
and say look the governor approved this
this $2 million for this project we have
three other smaller projects that add up
to 2 million we'd like to change that
right now that's the purview of this
committee we can go ahead and do that
that's why we get both both books with
us so and just for clarification the
when the agencies came to the governor
they asked for
1.1 billion dollars worth of projects
the catalog
has 400 just over $400 million in
general fund projects so you can see
it's been whittel down and then what
ended up in here is $143 Million worth
of capital
projects thank you for that matter of
fact I just labeled this as my catalog
so I don't forget what to call it this
is the catalog this is still the pink
one and the store so the the white
document is the bond offering statement
from last
April and I just wanted members to have
that it's broken into two parts it's
part one and part two so part one would
be dealing with the bond and explaining
what the state's trying to do there part
two is the demographic statistical
information that's the more in my
opinion I don't know if the treasure is
behind me yet but uh that's the more
interesting part of
it
and if you get to the
um the the second part I mean you're
going to find information on
demographics you're going to find County
information you're going to find you
just a wealth of information in there
including talking about the previous
capital budget and some of the items
related to that um but it's I think it's
a great resource I just wanted to make
the committee aware of it um so that
that's what I had
there other other than that I there's
not a lot I have to say um just a couple
of quick things Canon Mountain it was a
um appropriation for the
Tramway last uh last operating budget of
$18 million you're going to see in this
pink document there's a $20 million
request for the Tramway at Canon
Mountain the uh Governor aot is
recommending
to close out the $18 million that was
appropriated to um Department of Natural
and cultur resources for the Tramway so
that that money can be used to help
balance the budget and then has put it
in here for $20
million if for those of you that um have
been around you you've heard the
department mention in in within the last
year that when they went out to bid it
was closer to
3233 million to do the Tramway they were
going to be be looking at um the the
structural arms that hold the Tramway
and having some um Engineers come in to
make sure that those were sound because
I think the 33 or $32 million potential
cost was including taking those all down
um and the company that would provide
the trim didn't want to rely on the fact
that these might be old and could break
if they put their new equipment on it um
but that would be a question when they
come before you to really understand
what's going on with the Tramway and
what what's $20 million going to
buy and you got rid of the 18 so I just
wanted to make the committee aware of
that um would you you also uh walk the
committee through that came up back in
the long range Capital planning uh the
uh status of the prison the $40 million
why it's why we don't see anything in
there so the right now there's a $50
million appropriated to the Department
of Corrections to look at um a new
prison um they're using those funds to
assess the land behind the current
prison to see if they can um put the
Men's prison there right now they have
the women's prison that was put there
most recently um there's a lot of ledge
and a lot of other things that go on and
so they wanted to um take a look at that
land U make sure it was could support a
new Men's prison um as well as that Ed B
the bounce of the funds to do the uh
structural and Architectural um designs
that they could use to go out to bid
with so the question had come up at the
at a previous meeting is why isn't there
anything in house in the capital budget
proposal for the prisons a new prison um
I think and I suggest this and it may
will need to be followed up with
commissioner Hanks when she comes before
you but I think they may not need the
money in the next two years because of
the work they're doing to get ready to
put something out to bid it may be
needed at a later point also um last
spring the treasurer came before you and
talked about you may want to consider
this project differently than you do
other capital projects it may not be
something you put in House Bill 25 but
maybe there's a speal separate
legislative special that um puts the
appropriation for the new prison but
maybe staggers the appropriation out to
kind of go along with what the need
might be for the build so that you don't
appropriate $400 million all at once
maybe you do something slightly less in
the first couple years and then
depending on how long the project takes
but so there's some different ways of
looking at this and I don't want to
suggest that this is the only way but
that was kind of a conversation that was
had with this committee that U because
it is such a large project it maybe need
to be looked at a little bit differently
when it does come time to fully
appropriate it I believe the commit the
commitment to the prisons was $40
million a year for 10 years and we've
given them 40 actually 50 so far 50 uh
so I when I talked to Ken Wier at
Finance he said well we made that
commitment for 10 years but we didn't
necessarily mean that it was going to be
10 years in a row so
so that's why this year you're not going
to see 40 million in there for uh for
the prison but the commitment is still
there any anything else any questions
for Mr Shay Mr chairman yes represent
thank you Mr chairman a question do you
know have any idea has the Department of
Corrections told you or given you any
hint about when the design work for the
new prison Men's prison would be done uh
no no that I haven't had any direct
conversations related to that and again
that would would be um under your
purview when they come in um that they
definitely would I would suggest to the
committee that you ask them questions
about what's going on with the the
prison the potential for a new prison
particularly as you consider what types
of projects they're asking for in the
capital budget and what they might need
in the short term to um allow the Men's
prison to continue to operate in in a in
a way that's safe and and uh um
productive for the officers and the
inmates
um yes I don't have anything in
particular representative clud here
thank you Mr sh thank and just one last
comment and you know I as I indicated my
contact information is on that document
um feel free to email me call me you
can't find something or if you have a
question um reach out that's part of my
charge is to help you get the
information you need so that you can
make the decisions you have to make in
this
committee representative kazinski as a
reminder I think um that 50 million for
the corrections also included uh some
interest of about 27
million representative
Boger yeah if I could um thank you for
allowing my question and thank you for
taking my question it goes back to the
dramway where we had 16
million allocated I guess through a bond
for that project and now we want
to move that it was a cash
appropriation so that there was Cash
being appropriated towards that project
of $18
million the governor has um decided that
in order to make the budget work she
needs that cash in uh 2026 so there's a
language potentially in House Bill 2 or
the trailer bill that will um basically
lapse the remaining
amount to the general fund and then in
this oper in the capital budget the
recommendation is to provide $20 million
for the
Tramway thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you Mr
Shay Madam Treasurer you are up
next and before that I'd like to just
say the reason we have the treasure here
all the time is there's a there's lots
of bonding money to be done here as as a
general rule we look to the treasurer to
get us a figure that we can adhere
to whatever that figure is as a as a
guideline this committee has normally
tried to cut it by about $10
million as a general room we do that
only because after we pass this budget
and it goes to the Senate
the reason 24 Senators got voted in
instead of 400 Representatives is those
24 Senators have made many promises to
their areas and they need about they're
going to add about 10 million to it
which is why they'll pass their version
of the budget and then we'll finally
bang it out in a committee of conference
but it all
starts with Madam Treasurer who will
give
us a figure and I noticed the governor's
fig figure is at around 143 million and
in past I would guess for the past four
to six years we've been working between
1 120 and
130 so Madam Treasurer you're you're on
thank you Mr chairman good morning
everyone um for the record State
Treasurer Monica mapelli and thank you
again for inviting me today um so I know
you have a difficult task to try to uh
fund coupal projects and we usually know
there are a lot of requests uh that come
before the governor and and to you but
um so uh what I would like to just
provide you an overview of um obviously
some of uh or all of most of the most of
the projects are bonded um so um what I
would like to share is is how we see
things um you know from perspective of
the treasury when we are ready to is to
to issue bonds to fund those projects um
so um I'll try to say at a high level
but this presentation has essentially
what we what we look at our data
affordability so um I'll start with um
you know why we look at our data
affordability and is is primarily
because um B the boring costs are are
driven by the credit rating that uh
rating agencies uh assigned to the state
so um they look at um a variety of um
elements of of um
components of of the city of New
Hampshire so the economy they look at
the financial condition of our state our
operating results and the spite of that
obviously they they want to uh review
how um you know if we're able to issue a
balance budget or you know the type of
revenues that we have are they diverse
uh in case one of them doesn't uh
perform well they want to make sure
there's uh a variety of uh Revenue
sources that we can rely on uh the
amount of reserves we have how much
money we have rain fund um budgetary
pressures you know how much we approve
during budgets or operan budgets you
know the cost of Medicaid
post-employment
benefits retirement plans and of course
debt our debt burden and so that's what
we review at the treasury we're
responsible for making sure that the
state stays um maintains those uh prent
um debt management policy so to continue
with that so as you all know um the
state was upgraded ated um last year
because we've had um a very good uh
financial situation over the last few
years we're Revenue performing well um
maintaining our debt burden um
manageable so all of those pieces came
together and uh one of the rting
agencies um upgraded us so that was
great news so now the reality is um you
know we are we're facing a um a budget
year that is changing the the the
elements that helped us so we're still
one of the things that I always say our
debt we can we we can't really control
our revenues but we can manage our debt
so we look at our debt affability in two
in two ways we um we prepare a debt
affordability study and that study um
calculat that ratios that allow us to
see how we're doing um currently and how
we're going and how we're projected to
um uh over the next few years how those
ratios look like so uh on page three is
just a definitions you know I try to
describe what we do we have a DAT
affability side that we prepare every
year and also um the statute RSS 6C um
requires to calculate um how much more
the legislature can approve without
going to a limit so without passing the
limit and the limit is 10% of un
restrictive revenue of the previous
fiscal year so the law says the
legislature cannot approve a um
more um more debt than um if if it's
more than 10% of the existing debt plus
projected debt meaning already
everything that has been already
authorized so on page um on page
four I'm just um the the typical ratios
that we look at is the um debt to
revenue ratio that's the key key one the
rating agencies um review and as you can
see this is the um the r how the ratio
has performed over the years and we
obviously that has improved
significantly over the last 10 years so
2015 it was
8.2% in 2024 that ratio is 3.8% so we
look at that number um when we calculate
um those debt ratios we obviously we
want to be um really low because not
only we want to compare to um the median
and and and how other states the same
way we're rated
um again 3.8% is is is really uh an
excellent um number um and um we never
want to get too close to 10% 10% will
probably uh will equal a
downgrade so on page um on page five is
just a picture how our debt has changed
over time is um you know this this graph
shows how how much debt we had in
2006 it increased over the during the
financial crisis um the State issue
additional Bond I think there was a
restructuring of debt and and different
um there were different measures that
were taken during that time but again
since then uh we have improved
significantly in um in our our general
fund debt uh and and other debt that we
issue for um fishing game and others all
of all of them are are decreasing so
that's a really good picture
[Music]
here Bas six is just again it's a lot of
numbers here and but I just want to
focus on these are the ratios we
calculate and um I believe I shared
already the data affability study with
you and otherwise other other than that
I'll be happy to share with all of you
as posted on our website but we
calculate again the different ratios and
and and different dep metrics uh and we
compare those to how for example these
are um in this graph we're showing the U
medians according to
Moody and um the last one the the the
one that says Debt Service to general
fund revenues that that median is
actually um published by S&P Global and
that median is um for um for stasa rated
similar to us so double A Plus rated
States so and 2024 it shows the actual
ratios those ratios again are are really
um healthy ratios uh debt per capita
debt to revenue ratio uh compared to the
medians are really really excellent
numbers so um all of this are these
calculations are based on some
assumptions that we have to make um so
for example we we estimate or we assume
that the state is going to stay within
that 120 million per bium so we
calculate that every year is going to be
we're going to issue 60 million and in
this particular case we assume no
Revenue growth um uh so uh revenues
staying flat over the next few years
this this this study that we prepare we
we calculate different scenarios is is
is a way of um a stress test um that we
do for um to see how our debt is going
to perform compared to the median and
compared to how the state um the rating
agencies will uh will see the
state we're getting ready to uh issue
bonds again um in about two weeks we'll
have meetings with rating agencies that
have an opportunity to review us again
so showing a picture like this with this
ratios is really U um a positive a
credit positive for
us in and so
2025 uh through 28 in this in this um um
table again is based on issuing 60
million each year and in 2025 we assume
that we're going to issue the 40 million
that you folks were talking about U
related to the prison so that's and so
in 2025 we were assuming we're going to
issue a 100 million of bonds um I know
there was a question earlier about the
status of the person we don't typically
interact with the state agencies as to
how they doing with their expenditures
because we're assume it's typically
about the same amount that is that they
spend and and when they they they incur
those expenditures um that's when we
issue our bonds but um we learned that
the prison wasn't ready to to spend the
40 million so we we are not going to
bond um the 40 million in this year the
way we we had anticipated so at this
point we're just assuming we're going to
issue those Bonds in
2026 um again so we make assumptions and
we calculate ratios and and and and
again based on those assumptions
um you know we prepare our our
recommendations so um we we typically
stay or or or what I will say to you is
the the base cases 120 million for the
banum funded with General funds and the
reason for that as you can see we were
working towards uh reducing our ratio to
a point that is comparable to the median
so at this point in 2024 we are there um
when we're going to start issuing
additional Bond again staying within the
60 million per fiscal year and then we
add the 40 million that we was already
approved then our ratio start increasing
already so this is a fact there's really
nothing um um new so we already have you
know that that bonding has been
authorized so we're going to assume
that's going to be spent and so those
ratios going to start to
increase we don't know how revenues are
going to perform but but this is when
things um you know the ability to when
we say we want to stay within the 120
130 million is because of this reason
and that's the way we see it and of
course it doesn't answer the questions
that you all may have and the agencies
right it doesn't it doesn't um it
doesn't uh provide what agencies want to
hear but this is what we the way we see
it is just we want to maintain a um um a
debt um the debt levels are manageable
in a way that say can continue to afford
that and of course any additional debt
that this committee and and the
legislature approves um is additional
Debt Service that um needs to be paid uh
with operating funds um so that's the
the debt affordability picture that um
you know in in general we look
at on page
seven that's representative BR thank you
just a quick question uh in the previous
page you talked about the the $40
million for the prison being deferred to
2026 does this chart show that uh that
that change this RSA 6 C
chart is that reflected in this chart
follow me chart well the the so I'll
talk about this chart so this chart is
is according to the law we need to
calculate uh the debt limit um but we
have to include everything that has been
any any outstanding debt so Debt Service
already
um that we were paying existing Debt
Service and also anything that has we
have to project that service for
everything that has been authorized and
unissued so to answer your question it
includes everything not only the 40
million it includes so so the way this
chart is and this is just an attempt to
try to um respond to the law right so
there may be other ways to calculate
this um this limit but um the the second
column um um
from left to right it shows uh
everything that has been authorized and
issu so right now is
3744 million that has been authorized
and issued um the First Column shows
actual uh uh Debt
Service and then we also have to
include all the all the debt that the
state has guaranteed so this is that
that the state is um um you know if
there is a need to to to to to um step
in and pay for that debt is everything
so anything that has been authorized uh
for the uh business Finance Authority uh
peace Development Authority they have um
some um authorizations and the state um
guarantees their debt so all all of that
needs to be included in this calculation
so um so it's everything um that the
state has promised and so the the law
says no more than 10% can be can be can
be authorized um if if the existent if
the existent and projected debt is going
to be more so when we finished all these
calculations it correlates to another
billion dollars in bond and
authorization I never gonna um suggest
that you do that but I guess bottom line
is this this law um provides for a um a
limit un you which is different than
this the federal government
um the state state law provides a limit
and but it's a generous limit I guess I
will say U because we never want to get
to that 10% we always want to maintain
it again as I showed you before in a in
a manageable way we want to stay within
those medians and and so we can maintain
that uh credit rate and that allows us
to keep um the the borrowing law Bor and
cost
low and so so this is a calculation we
have to provide it we we we provide this
to um the legislative budget assistant
every year and and again this is uh
required by law thank
you so on page eight is just um you know
just a summary of um again a few points
that um you know key take key
takeaways um so clearly the state has
capacity to borrow more there's no doubt
and even if revenues um
if if revenues continue to um you know
not perform according to how we want
them to perform the state will still has
the ability to to to borrow more um but
again um any additional Bond and
authorization that we have to that we
have to um again go out and issue bonds
that will increase obviously The Debt
Service and and and the state's ability
to um to pay that debt
um right as I mentioned earlier the that
we can manage our debt obligations but
revenues is you know is is what's a
little more um um difficult to to
anticipate and and the one point I just
want to mention in
and just is a is a reminder of sometimes
I see projects and and I don't fully
know the the useful lives of some of
those projects but a reminder that we
issue bonds for 20 years we amortise
that debt for over 20 years so anything
that they're useful life of those
projects is is less than that number I
guess I would just um um recommend that
you you you review that and and and you
make a decision accordingly but at least
you know keep that in mind that we're
borrowing uh for a period of 20 years
and if there are if there is no need to
include certain equipment that doesn't
live that long doesn't last that long is
is is for you to consider so that's what
I had uh for prepare remarks I'll be
happy to answer any additional questions
well I will ask the first question which
is uh once again I heard you say the the
magic 120 million I know you're very
comfortable with that I know last year
you were very comfortable because we
threw out 130 million how comfortable
are you with 143 million right
now I was actually not um fully aware
that that was going to be the number I
was here in the 130 million so um I
think I think it's a decision 4 million
seems again if we could as as you
mentioned I'm not sure what the what the
Senate will do or um so if we start
changing our our math um I just I just
showed you the math if we start changing
the math then that's how we're um you
know we'll get um again we perhaps need
to find a a a more um um number that we
want to work with and and the re and I
always hear
um the the cost of projects have incre
increased uh inflation and all of that
and I fully recognize that but my job is
to calculate those numbers to stay
within those numbers right so um I would
say 140 seems a bit high in my opinion
but but it's it's not again the state
can afford that um is is really um if
the state wants to stay within 100 140 I
will say 130 is a little better um once
again we we never want to hold you to
any of this this is this is not for this
is just for our yes internal use working
here uh would would 135 be an equitable
number that sounds reasonable to me I
guess you find I'll find a compromise
number right this this this gives us a
place that we can start as a committee
and saying we're comfortable with it
because quite
frankly even looking at the intelligence
of this committee I don't think anybody
understood what you said on those first
eight pages that's why we always maybe
I'm oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah baloney
don't please don't give me that anyway
that's why the chair always' task was
asking this this dollar figure thank you
Mr chairman thank you yeah no I I tried
to explain it in a way that I feel like
U you'll be able to understand it but
essentially is really we we crunch the
numbers to try to show you um that
currently we're doing really well the
city is doing really well uh the debt
management practices of the state of the
last few years has paid off and so stay
with within those boundaries is will be
will be prudent uh but again I know you
have the difficult task to approve uh
Cal projects but I think um you again
staying within those numbers um uh
finding a good balance there I think
that that should be that should be
appropriate thank you representative
bogert thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my questions I actually
have two questions if that's
okay the first one's on P
six going back to the net Debt Service
to general fund revenues is those
percentages
cumulative when it's like for 25 it says
4.4% is that a cumulative of all of our
debt and so that when we're at that 10%
Mark that you were talking about we're
only using total 4.4 4%
approximately to that
10% that's correct that's that's that's
total it's cumulative so it's it's is
it's total debt um this this number does
not include uh on page six this number
does not include
um um debt guaranteed by the state but
we do in the study we prepare another
chart that shows that and so when we
include um assuming which is would be
very unlikely but assuming the state
were to um pay all that debt has been
guaranteed um the the number increases
by uh 100 basis points so another per uh
another 1% so even with that even if the
state were to PID everything
um the number still um manageable okay
follow followup please thank you and you
mentioned the
uh the uh 60 million per year so that's
100 20 and then you said we were going
to fast forward over to 2640 million so
for the 26 we have to look at 160
million is that what I understood that
would
be possibly bonded yes so in 26 it will
be 100 million because it will be the 40
million plus a 60 but again if if this
Committee of you know the the the final
product of the capital budget is is more
than that then we'll just add another
five or 10 million um the amount that
you're going to Pro follow please so
thank you um so if we're looking for
that 100 million already for
26 does that uh the question previously
asked was about that 135 million for the
b b Minal or for the two years uh
so that number is already going to be
skewed no this is cumulative she you're
you're talking about she's giving you
cumulative numbers that are coming up
not 100 well I was talking about the 160
or the 100 million for 26 is already
that would be the 60 that we would have
capital budget room for plus the 40 for
the prison that's 100 million
already yes but it's it's all included
in here so we so again the the the
anomaly here was the 40 million um but
but the math again is is is is 60 to 70
million um for each each year of the
bium that's what you get and the only
anomaly will be adding 40 million
whenever we issue that so we're not
going to issue in 25 but we're going to
issue in 26 um so it will reflect it
will just the the ratio will start
increasing then rather than so for
example 25 may stay around the
4% um but then going forward it will
increase um again just because of the uh
we will bond that additional 40 million
if that makes sense thank you
representative Jack uh thank you isn't
the 40 million was was authorized but
unissued in a prior term so it's already
counted in there correct yeah that's
what we're that's what we're including
in the math representative
fauler thank you I think we're trying to
get this ma turn not right but we issue
new Debt Service $60 million a year but
we are also paying off some of the debt
that's out there so that the net
increase is not 60 million it's
something less than that is that correct
and and the and the 60 million is just
the assumption but you're correct so so
this calculation includes those new
issues where we're paying off and and
and what happens to us we don't we don't
always issue the exact 60 million right
we issue we issue bonds based on how
soon the agent spend that money so if
they haven't spent the money like in the
case of the prison we're not going to
issue bonds we're going to wait until
they're ready to to to um to spend those
funds so there are times that we issue
less than 60 but again it's it's just
less or more so again it's all it's just
a you know on average that's what we
typically talk about and this is all
paid with General funds represent bone
thank you Mr chairman uh
question uh uh so we currently owe 525
million in
bonds that is correct and that's um on
page six that is that is correct and
that is um that is um um
just um what we call net tax supported
debt so pay with General
funds follow how much is left on the
school building Aid because I used to be
on education I've been following it for
years
year so it's actually um let me get that
number shouldn't have been there
anyway so just to to answer your
previous question so um we actually all
uh we allow less for uh general fund is
about 400 million right now but School
Bill and a is um uh we have about $30
million left
outstanding and that we're going to pay
that off in
2029 okay coming tou down on the amount
of building
heat thank you you're welcome any
further
questions seeing none thank you madam
treasur it's been very very very in
enlightening and I think we've got our
our little old magic number to work with
here pleasure Mr chairman thank you very
much thank
you um this committee I Think We're not
scheduled now to meet till March 4th a
Tuesday and we will uh will'll be
hitting the ground running at 10:00 a.m.
I think we're scheduled through till 3
in the afternoon uh we've done things a
little bit differently this year we used
to schedule them in half hour 45 minutes
an hour depends and uh on M Mr Shay's
suggestion we've lumped them all
together so that we won't have any we'll
take our own little breaks in between as
necessary but we won't have any of the
Dead periods in between you know if we
allocated somebody for an hour and they
took 20 minutes we would have to sit
here for 40 minutes twiddling our thumbs
so instead we're going to be able to
just take them in a row and get them
done as quickly as we can and utilize
our time
efficiently Mr Shay anything to wrap up
uh so at the near the end of the week
I'll shoot an email to everybody um that
will have the um loose schedule for the
agencies for next Tuesday so as the
chair has indicated in the calendar it
will show at 10:00 you're starting um
it'll show the agencies in the order
that they're going to present so it'll
be Department of administrative Services
doit governor's office in the morning
what I'll send you is I've asked the
agencies you have an hour ad
administrative Services 60 Minutes um
doit you have a half hour governor's
office you have a half hour so I'll give
you that schedule just so you kind of
see how long an agency should be taking
but the whole point was if you have an
agency who's scheduled for an hour and
they take 30 minutes you can go right
into the next agency and keep
moving representative fauler are are
they able to uh stand by in their oppos
I don't hate to have all these people
waiting here that was the reason for the
what I would say behind the scen
schedule or I said you know plan on
speaking for 60 minutes plan on speaking
for 30 minutes um The Hope is that the
agencies that are next in line will pay
attention and know to be here if they if
they think that agency is not going to
take the full amount of time if I'm made
aware beforehand I will also let the
agencies know so if uh just say
Department of administrative Services
came in and said we're going to be done
in like 10 minutes well would let theit
know to please come in or schedule
another agency in addition
to um but yeah at this point you got two
days of hearings scheduled it should
cover all the
agencies um unless there's a you know an
agency or two that you need to bring
back and then we would have to schedule
another day to do that and then there'll
be the usual lapse extension meeting um
that will be potentially March 14th is
the tentative date we've been telling
the agencies we're doing it a little bit
differently this time and that we've
asked I've asked the agencies to report
on their laps extensions as part of the
presentation to the full committee uh I
noted in the last couple cycles that
sometimes members who aren't part of
that committee their subcommittee felt
like they didn't know why some of the
decisions were made as it related to the
lapse extension so this gives everybody
the same information and then at a later
point they the chair will have a
subcommittee work on finalizing the laps
extensions and Laps extensions for new
members are basically cap capital
projects um that the agencies would like
to have continue without this lapse
extension they would they would truly
lapse at the end of the bium the
authority to spend the money would go
away so agencies that you know for
example with the um $40 million for the
prison they'll need an an extension to
make sure that money doesn't lapse
um and and it's it's the back pages of
that pink document that I gave you
there's probably 150
um items that agencies have asked to to
not lapse for various reasons and and
this committee goes through that pretty
intently um to make sure that there
items that are there should be there
items that didn't make the list that
should be are added and then um if
there's a any available funds remaining
um this committee has in the past tried
to repurpose those funds to projects
that you would like to have money go to
um but it's all dependent on how much uh
um is available through the laps
extension process and that's never known
truly until we get done that
process but that that's all I
got anybody any further questions
comments representative cludia yes thank
you Mr chairman right next week we are
only going to meet on Tuesday the 4th is
that correct correct and then until the
following week we will continue is that
correct and your intention is to go the
on Tuesday I noticed the following week
is town meeting day I don't know if
we're going to come in and meet
I Monday uh March 10th some reps I don't
know I don't care I'm in but so next
week we we've got agencies coming in on
Tuesday the following week it's the
Monday because it was consideration
given for town meeting
concerns thank you Mr
chair anything
else 11
we're out of here adjourned okay thank
you for